my name is Sean Morrison I direct the
University of Michigan Center for stem
cell biology state of Michigan had been
one of the states in this country with
the most restrictive laws when it comes
to embryonic stem cell research it was
legal in the mission in Michigan to
throw embryos away that had been created
during in in vitro fertilization clinics
and in fact for a variety of reasons
large numbers of embryos are routinely
discarded from those clinics that cannot
be used for fertility treatment so it
was legal to throw embryos away but it
was not legal to take the embryos that
were being thrown away and used them to
drive embryonic stem cell lines that
could be used in medical research that
might one day help patients this was
really blocking the ability stem cell
research to develop in the state of
Michigan in a way that other states with
major research universities didn't have
to contend with so we within the
University of Michigan work to try to
improve those state laws initially
trying to work through the legislature
and when that didn't work we went
straight to the people of Michigan
knowing that there was broad bipartisan
support among the people of the state
for expanded embryonic stem cell
research much like in other states it
turns out that we as scientists have to
be involved in the public policy process
because if you're not involved you get
bad laws for bad reasons policies end up
being created partly out of ignorance
partly out of other agendas that can
oftentimes destroy opportunities to make
people's lives better so during the
proposal to campaign we spent a lot of
time thinking about how to explain what
stem cell research really was what was
at stake how it could be done more
effectively and how it would potentially
help the people of Michigan part of that
process was in polling and doing focus
groups to try to understand what the
public understood
the public thought about the research
what aspects of the research needed to
be explained more and how we could best
help people to understand and in that
process there were a lot of surprises
about what the public really understood
what the public was worried about and
how we could best understand it
unfortunately our opponents were also of
course doing polling and focus groups
except they were looking for what they
could use to most frightened the public
to cause people to not support the
ballot proposal politics 101 is if you
want people to vote against an issue you
frighten and confuse them and so sadly
the opponents of the proposal to
campaign when they realized in their own
focus groups and polling that that none
of the true messages about what the
proposal was really about actually
resonated with the public and actually
frightened them they decided to run a
one hundred percent false campaign where
they made stuff up to frighten and
confuse the public that just wasn't true
their first message was vote against
proposal too because it'll increase your
taxes well there was no funding
associated with the proposal there was
nothing had nothing to do with taxes but
they learned in their polling that
people were frightened of new taxes
their second message was that crazy
scientists wanted to mix human DNA with
animal eggs to try to clone half people
half animals and they would dress actors
up in cow suits and put them on TV to
try to frighten people into this brave
new world that they would create by
voting for a proposal to in fact again
was obviously a false and ludicrous
suggestion particularly given that
cloning remains illegal in the state of
Michigan prop 2 dealt with the ability
to for to give patients the right to
donate for research embryos that were
created by in vitro fertilization and
that would otherwise be discarded if not
donated for research so it put that
right back into patients hands as it is
in most other states within the country
to decide what they do with their own
embryos rather than leaving those
decisions with the state legislature
finally they argued that stem cell
research was akin
the Tuskegee syphilis experiments which
was a terrible period in the history of
American Medical Research in which
minority sharecroppers were victimized
in the course of medical research
experiments but of course that was a
turning point in the development of our
current notions about medical ethics and
patient protection and nothing like that
could ever happen again as a result of
federal laws and other kinds of state
laws and and the more sophisticated
notions we have about what medical
research should be and so there was no
truth to that claim but yet they felt
they had an opportunity to frighten the
voters well there was widespread
coverage in the media a partly because
of the efforts of scientists to explain
what the research was really about and
why the opposition claims were false
there was widespread coverage in the
media about how false the opposition
claim was and it eventually during the
campaign engendered anger in the general
population about how this special
interest group was trying to defeat this
proposal by tricking the voters into
voting against their own self-interest
and against their own values what we
learned as a result of that campaign is
that hope and truth prevail over fear
and misinformation and that scientists
can play a really critical role in
making sure that the right thing happens
in the end by being clear and by
spending the time to explain the
research to the general public in one of
the interesting things that we learned
as a result of the polling that we did
prior to the campaign was that we asked
people to rank sources of information in
terms of credibility and we listed 10
different sources of information your
friends and family your physician your
pastor university professors etc and
number one in terms of credibility was
university professors university
professors are perceived as people who
are in the business of education and who
are trying to explain things to the
public and it's so it's important for us
to get engaged and as a
we had the presumption of credibility
when we engaged with the merchants of
fear and misinformation in the debate uh
and so we we owned the moral high ground
in this debate because we had the
capacity to defend our position by
telling the truth and the more the truth
came out during the debate the more
likely we were to win whereas the
opposition had to lie in order to
convince people to vote in the way that
they wanted well according to every rule
of thumb in Michigan politics we should
have lost that campaign the rule of
thumb is that if you want people to vote
YES on a proposal you have to outspend
the opponent's two to one well it was
one to one because we were up against a
well-funded opposition the rule of thumb
is that you have to go into the election
day with about a ten percent lead in the
polls because undecided voters break
disproportionately to know on Election
Day and yet we were going in neck and
neck into election day so the day before
the election I saw comments from ten
different political pundits nine of whom
said the proposal was going to go down
to defeat and yet three different news
organizations did exit polling
throughout the state on the day of the
election and all in every case the exit
polls were so clearly trending toward
the yes side that all three news
organizations unofficially called it in
our favor when the polls closed at 8pm
that night so it was a remarkable
experience because we could see that
when you could explain things clearly to
the public the public would have an
opportunity to really make up their mind
based on the merits of the issue and to
see through the tactics and a fear and
confusion that often pervade political
debates and going forward in this area
it will be particularly important for
more science to be more scientists to be
engaged in these kinds of processes both
to defend the public investment in in
medical research as well as to create
effective laws and as young people come
up through the system and become
scientists for them to understand that
part of their job is not just to work in
the laboratory and to do their work but
explain to the public
why it's valuable for the public to
invest in that work
you